[Music]
uh so today's Community Day all the pars
of the US Championship are going to
schools around St Louis and you know
teaching kids um openings and games uh
tactics doing some fun stuff like hand
and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision- making skills planning skills
and I see them apping that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I played with my
auntie my sisters sometimes on the
weekends like we go to the park and we
play they begging me to teach them I
like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make better decisions in life I can tell
you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically and moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complexity of
Chess how you have to think about every
single move you make like every move you
make whether is going to put your king
in check whether it's going to put put
your anything in
danger whether it's just a move that you
make everything counts in the long run I
like um how it makes me use my critical
thinking makes me look at the whole
board I think it's teaching them to be
persistent you know we have a lot of
students who it takes them like it may
take a few weeks or even months in chess
club to master a particular strategy or
skill um and what I think that teaches
kids is even if they don't get it the
first time around or even if it's
difficult the first time around um it's
worth sticking to it well one thing's
for certain without the St Louis chess
club we would not have chess instructors
because I don't know if you all know
this but there is a critical shortage of
teachers and Educators and especially
those in areas that are not core content
area and because of the St Louis chess
club collaboration we have people who
come in here working with students who
want to work with them today with the
experience of The Grandmaster community
outreach day I came up and I'm like well
what's a Grandmaster and they like oh
you don't know what a Grandmaster is and
they were able to explain that and they
recognize the importance and the
seriousness I mean it's a sport it's a
profession and so they're able to see
things outside of the sports that we
typically promote in school makes me
feel good because like learning stuff
like this will help me learn help me
build my problem solving skills help me
build strategy and like you know help my
brain